now I've been inspired lately
by the current champion of China who's
that you surd you know who yeah that's
him Wei Yi yeah exactly
thank you for weighing in on the subject
and he just turned 16 a few weeks ago
and he's rated in the top 30 in the
world and he played a brilliant game
which I'm sure you're all familiar with
against the Cuban player bruise on in
the tournament in China where he
sacrificed a lot of material and bruised
ons King ran around the board and I'm
already lectured about that game in this
class actually now it reminded me of a
couple of other games that I've played
in my life one was in 1992 which I
showed in the earlier class and one was
in 1993 which I will show now the reason
it reminded me of that was I also
sacrificed all of my pieces and like
wayy I made a couple of waiting moves
well not waiting moves but moves that
improve my position even though I was
down a thousand pieces now the
difference between Wei Yi and me is that
his sacrifices were on purpose okay so
my game was of course the Sicilian I
have the black pieces case my comer
watches the video the blacks on the
bottom and we play what's called the
open Sicilian where white plays d4 and
then everybody takes everything and
everybody's happy now as some of you
know there's a chess tournament ongoing
right now at the Chess Club and
Scholastic Center there's a grandmaster
norm tournament and I noticed about 15
minutes ago one of the games in that
tournament follows this game for quite
some time
okay Knights out Bishop out this is
called the rouser variation some call it
the Richter rouser like the computer
does
named after two people and what's good
about this opening if you like to win is
you usually have opposite side castling
one side castles here one side castles
there then they checkmate each other
sometimes the game ends in a draw with
the simultaneous checkmate right yeah no
would be correct right okay so that's
what we did and this is the game
currently being played as I speak
although not for you at home for you at
home it was like two weeks ago between
Ron Burnett white and LaVon rigazzi
black and if you go to the US chess
champs comm website and look up round
six of the the GM Rome tournament you'll
see this position or if when the class
is over if you walk over to the Chess
Club you'll see this position although
they've put a lot of move sense okay and
I Castle Knight to b3 now in this
position most grandmasters play f4 which
is very scary and that's the move that I
face a lot now two players you may have
heard of them you've definitely heard of
one of them well I wouldn't say
definitely Anatoly Karpov and Nigel
short now in the 1970s and 80s and 90s
Karpov was busy he was busy losing that
Shizuka's far off that took all of his
time occasionally he would even draw a
match occasionally a match would end
with no result
very suspicious but true anyway if
Karpov played somebody else a match that
means Karpov won he beat everybody every
match except Kasparov well in 1993 maybe
something like that although this game
was played in 93 so now I'm very
suspicious of that Karpov quite a match
was short and short won the match and in
game 10 the last game of the match they
got this position and Nigel short played
Knight to b3 now why would why
retreat thanks for asking because white
is retreating but he's unleashing the
latent potential of the Queen and rook
on the D pawn and in the game that I
referred to earlier Nigel short Karpov
Karpov played a six Nigel short played
Bishop takes f6 do you think Karpov took
with the bishop or the pawn yes taking
what the bishop is solid except it loses
a pawn although some grandmasters do
play that Karpov took with the Jeep on
and eventually lost and then short
played Gaspar for the World Championship
maybe depends who you ask if you ask
lead a they didn't play if you ask
anybody else they did ok that's a long
story that's not part of this class ok
so instead of a six
I played the move Queen to b6 now let's
pretend that white wants to win the pawn
in the same way Bishop takes Knight
Bishop takes Bishop yeah it's a free
pawn now that pawn is not as free as you
thought because black can take upon what
move can black play here it takes a pawn
yeah
Queen takes this pawn right that's why I
played Queen b6 very good now my
opponent saw that
so after Queen b6 he played f3 now I
can't take that pawn because it's not
there now if it was White's movie would
take by night and take my pawn
so I defended my pawn with rigged d8 now
the theme of that would be overworked or
as Julian would say overloaded the
bishop is defending two things
so if white takes one that he could take
the other once the bishop moves away
however after work to DA
my rook is defending my pawn so I'm not
worried about that anymore
okay he attacked my queen but I saw it
and I retreated okay now he played what
I like to call a low-rated players move
and you're all low rated so you're going
to like this move you'd be like oh boy
that's my kind of move grandmasters try
to improve their position putting their
pieces on good squares so if white was a
grandmaster white would push his King
side pawns trying to checkmate black or
white would play King b1 making his King
safe probably if I was white I would do
some crazy pawn pushing rarh my opponent
attacked my queen am I not going to see
it and he played Knight b5 no
grandmaster would ever play that move
low-rated players love that move they're
like oh boy I attacked a queen see how I
was Knight attacks my queen so I moved
my queen away that was easy and my
opponent played Queen f2 I had play d5
because I like to play in the center and
we traded and I checked him and he saw
it and I attacked his Knight now my
opponents Knight is attacked because I
said so and if he goes back to a normal
square I would play Knight takes Knight
check and then I would take his rook and
then he would resign my opponent didn't
lose all of his pieces could have played
94 but he attacked my night C 4 and C 4
is very good somebody who's going to
class now one of my favorite things to
do in chess is to activate my pieces
without moving them it's sort of like
exercising without moving okay I like
that right again now you see my rook on
a eight in the corner that didn't move
did it normally you would move your rook
into the center and your rooks would be
active but I took his knight and he took
my knight and now my rooks on an open
file near his King okay and we traded
pawns okay now when I played this game
in 1993 and I analyzed it over the
following years with a chess engine the
chess engine didn't like this next move
however chess engines have improved and
now they like my moves and I played a
pawn sacrifice I wanted my bishop to
jump through this pawn and attack his
King can bishops jump over pawns hmm no
but if my pawn wasn't there that my
bishop could move freely
so I sacrificed upon d4 he was very
anxious to take this free pawn and now
white is a pawn ahead and I played the
a4 mentioned Bishop e6 and now I'm
attacking the a to pawn thusly and he
didn't want to lose his a to pawn so he
played b3 blocking my bishop okay now
over the years I've gone crazy okay you
can ask anybody especially Spencer he'll
back me up completely Spencer's my son
or anybody else who knows me and this is
the first time I went crazy that I
remember I made moves that lost all of
my pieces but it was an accident
when way he did it and the Chinese in
the well huh it wasn't the Chinese
championship it was a tournament after
when way he did it it was on purpose
okay
so I decided my queen was not well
placed and I played queen f4 and he
attacked my queen and I did a fork Queen
f5 check I think the King side diner is
a fine place to show a fork right I
think way he didn't have any Forks in
his games what would he do
chopsticks yeah maybe hit a piano no
nothing
what's that well you know they're
laughing at home
okay now I'm attacking the king and I'm
attacking the bishop I'll be hurt the
hands rubbing on the naan the feet on
the audio
how does white save his bishop he
doesn't want to lose his bishop does he
how does he save his bishop and stop
check don't I'll shout it out at once
what's that - b6 what's that while it's
d3 but yeah it's six because you're
going that way exactly it would normally
be g6 or e6 okay so he played Bishop to
d3 now I did something reserved for weak
players so maybe I'm a weak player
probably I touched my queen I moved it
and I said wait a minute that move sucks
and I put it back because I didn't let
go yet and I was like hmm all of my
plans are ruined okay luckily family guy
wasn't on yet so they weren't ruined now
Queen h3 is safe I could move over here
but I'm not really attacking his king
then his Kings over here so I decided at
this point to give all my pieces away
what's better than taking somebody's
pieces check me so I figured if I
checkmate him it would be worth it all
so I could lecture about it for years to
come I wasn't thinking that
so I played Queen a5 and when I play
Queen f4 let's go back when I play Queen
for here I envisioned g3 Czech Bishop d3
here and I was like wow my queen and
rook are lined up I'm the greatest then
when I played Queen a5 I was like wait a
minute my opponent has a fork which
heretofore I had overlooked what move
can white play that Forks two of black's
pieces but if it's any quieter I'll call
people at home then Simon what's the
answer this should be six attacking my
queen and my rook and I'm like wow
that's what happens in chess I moved my
queen and he took my rug and I decided
I'll try to checkmate him I played
Bishop takes be three so now black is
behind a rook but I have an attack on
his King and he doesn't really have an
attack on my King and he took my bishop
on g5 now white is ahead a ruck and a
bishop I hate when that happens
however I was reminded of this game
looking at the wayy game so I figure
I'll show it maybe way you saw this game
and it was inspired in his own game ok
so I played Bishop takes a to check and
he moved his King
alright now the whole point of the
lecture is this position okay and this
would be generally reserved for players
over 2200 but will still let Paul have a
chance at it okay so this position white
is ahead a rook and a bishop and White's
plan is to run his King over to the
Kings side okay like over the other
Kings side not the Kings side here so
what most people do is they go check
check check check check check then we're
out of checks they resign because you're
down a rook at a bishop however it would
be preferable if White's King didn't run
away and White's King stayed on c2 why
could checkmate him
so what move did I make stopping his
King from running away how can black
stop White's King from running the
safety what did I do
and your hand was almost up is it up
caspin yeah are you talking about this
open file yeah that's not so bad that's
a pretty good move unfortunately I think
Y can block that file with something
like disappea 4 or by doing some magic
trick magic okay how'd that even happen
okay I don't think I don't think it's
even allowed in chess piece it reminds
me one time I was blocked by somebody on
Facebook amazing and I still got stuff
through and they said you broke Facebook
they were very impressed they weren't
mad that I got through the block and
really how'd you do that so somehow I
made an illegal move something was good
okay so instead of Riki eight which
isn't a bad move we have another
suggestion over here Queen to b4 right
yeah now the king can go here because
that's illegal now to show you how
difficult chess is if you let stockfish
six think for about thirty seconds it
plays rook to b1 a very strange rule
because I take a check and then like
rook check when's your queen
that's computers for you it says whites
very slightly better he's up a rook and
a bishop so my opponent played socks
fishes second move pretty good because
there's a lot of moves here play Bishop
efore this way the King can run away
okay and I played check and now
stockfish says king b1 is a viable move
walking into discovered check taking
your rook because if I take the rook you
block and white still up a bishop and
White has a lot of threats Queen takes
Queen rook takes Bishop so after king b1
stockfish suggests this is a reasonable
way for the game to end however my
opponent
five hundred and fifty points lower
rated he said yeah I like to lower a tip
I have an extra ricotta Bishop which
reminds me of a funny bridge story who
had to edit this out because it's really
boring Barry crane nom cake very crane
the most famous bridge player ever and
the craziest by far the craziest and the
producer of the Mission Impossible
television show is a Hollywood producer
he was considered the greatest bridge
player played the most master points but
anyway that's beyond their scope he was
playing against an elderly couple that
you know weren't very good and at some
point the couple doubled the stakes of
the contract and Barry crane said do not
many mast your points I have and she
said nope but I know how many high card
points I have that's what my opponent
was thinking I might be higher rated but
he has a lot more pieces so if he wanted
he didn't want to draw even though I'm
higher rated because he has thousand
extra pieces so instead of drawing with
king b1 although I wouldn't have drawn a
pilot of lost
he played King to d3 which is okay and I
played Bishop c4 check and he played
King to e3 and now I did a fork hooray
how did I fork the king and the bishop
we can't ask Barry crane we can't do it
no it's okay how does black attack the
king and the bishop yeah
Queen c5 now white can actually save his
King and Bishop he doesn't want to
because if he saves his King and Bishop
then I take his Queen that's a little
too much so he blocked with his rook and
I played Queen takes g5 check now even
if you fallen asleep you can find the
right move here for white leave here
sleep you can't White is in check what's
the only way out of check yeah
block it f4 then I checked him again
Rick a3 check now White has three legal
moves he could move his king or he can
block with his rook or bishop if he
moves his king now what Queen goes over
here and we have three pieces attacking
your king your King will not survive the
computer announces maid innate in this
position a sample variation would be
here check checkmate
okay so my opponent didn't want to get
checkmated so he blocked now when Wei Yi
sacrificed all of his pieces
he ended up checkmating his opponent
though his opponent resigned before he
got checkmated in this game where I
sacrificed all of my pieces I ended up
winning them all back so I was a pawn up
in an end game I played rook takes rook
check Queen c5 check if he moves his
King here I take his bishop with check
notice how his queen is attack so he
can't do that
or I guess he couldn't
if he moves his king bat to protect his
queen
checkmate and now the most illegal move
of all time is not possible castles
illegal for many reasons all the reasons
well the ricotta h1 didn't move it's not
all the reasons but in check through
check in to check and the king moved I
think only the rook moving is the other
reason right
almost every reason possible okay so my
opponent played King f3 and I did a
skewer if you don't know what a skewer
is then you can't solve it skewers when
you attack a big piece and a little
piece behind it it's the opposite of a
pin you pin a small piece to a big piece
if you switch them that's a skewer how
can I skewer the king and the rook with
Wyatt with the Queen but then his Bishop
would block and I would cry it so I
checked with the bishop now if his
Bishop blocks
he's the one who's crying because if he
takes my Bishop I take his Queen so he
moved his king and we traded everything
and after all that rigmarole I'm up upon
years later I saw this gentleman again
another tournament on the west coast or
Nevada somewhere and he was very upset
that he lost this ending he thought it
should be a draw I disagree I think
black should win with his outside past
pawn he wasn't upset that he was a rook
at a bishop ahead and he got to this
that was fine but losing this endgame
really upset him now in this position my
opponent did something crazy in this
position if I remember correctly I
notice my King can't move anywhere they
can't move forward because that would be
illegal right but my opponent was very
nice he's like no no come on in and take
my pawns very nice gentleman he played
Bishop c4 track and I'm like ok and now
how do you save your pawn
how do you stop me from taking it with
the king and then I go take the other
pun that you can't stop
so Bishop c4 was was quite a bad move he
thought if he did nothing he would draw
years later I leave it up to Magnus
Carlsen to decide that I think blacks
should win but it take about 50 more
moves if I'm lucky anyway he made it
quite easy then I took another pawn now
I'm two pawns up yay okay and then I
have to pass pawns and he gave up here
because now I'm going to get two queens
or three Queens or four Queens right you
could only get three I only have three
pawns yeah well what if I was playing
bughouse and didn't know it and I just
realized it that makes sense so there's
two ways to win when you sacrifice
material for a mating attack one is the
wayy method of checkmating your opponent
one of my favorite games the other is to
win your material back while your
checkmating your opponent
they're throwing pieces in the way to
stop from getting mated and now you're
ahead material now in my 60 memorable
games Fischer's famous book he talked
about a game where he was sacrificing
material and checkmating his opponent
and in some position he could have just
taken pieces and won the endgame very
easy and he said they don't give
brilliancy prizes for endgame technique
so instead of winning the endgame he
kept playing for checkmate and
eventually he won although I didn't do
that because I couldn't check me and he
kept running around so this is what we
call double-edged complex chess you take
something good you know and something
bad you know and they both happen at the
same time it's good when you're
checkmating your opponent it's bad when
they're taking all of your pieces but
what if they happen at the same time
well if you checkmate them you win if
you don't then you're done a lot of
pieces that's why it's very risky and
scary to do that
I don't do that very often yes
yeah wayy does it all the time because
he calculates 100 moves ahead and I can
so certain players like more as David
Sharov Gaspar of tall alec ein see who
else that's it sometimes Nakamura they
play wild and crazy chests sacrifice
material checkmate their opponent other
players like lekha Karpov Petrosian Smee
Slav they don't do that they play boring
and then when you fall asleep example
over there then they take your pieces
high you're not awake so I usually like
the method of putting my opponent to
sleep but here I sort of accidentally
sacrificed material so I had to go with
it that happens I had to checkmate my
opponent I had no choice and some people
like to do that I do that as a last
resort sacrificing my pieces and the
most famous saying about sacrificing
your pieces is sacrifice your opponent's
pieces right taking their pieces is good
and now as Dave argon Ian said after I
won this game class dismissed